does anyone else find it really odd that
despite the overwhelming similarities
between the Egyptians and the Incas that
mainstream scientists archeologists and
the textbooks that are being taught in
school completely omit any of this
information take for example the step
pyramids that are found both in Peru
ancient Egypt and Cambodia does anyone
else think that that's an accident or
just a coincidence wait a second wait a
second the ancients were dumb of course
it's a coincidence heck if you give some
kids some toy blocks they're going to
build random things up and of course
you're going to find similarity
somewhere right but wait a second what
about the incredible similarities with
the use of trapezoidal doors found both
with the Incas and in the Egyptian
cultures trapezoidal doors nevermind
that that's only found in those two
cultures it's obviously definitive
evidence that they were so primitive
that they were incapable of building
anything with a straight line but what
about the incredible similarities of the
use of gold funeral masks on their
mummies or the fact that both these
cultures would cross the arms of their
mummies Gold funeral masks so what fact
if anything that just proves that they
didn't have the ability to dip them in
rhodium and make white gold obviously
and crossing the arms of the mummies oh
come on the ancients were cold blooded
Neanderthals they're probably just
through the bodies of the mummies into
their sarcophagus and did away with them
and heck I wouldn't be surprised if the
arms of the mummies are simply crossed
over after they were dumped in by
accident come on wait a second so how do
you explain the fact that Egyptian
mummies have been found with traces of
cocaine in them I mean after all cocaine
is exclusively native of South America
so how do you explain that Egyptian
mummies would have cocaine in them
despite the inability to cross the
oceans you're kidding right you don't
need to go to South America to get
cocaine heck go to the south side of
town and find yourself a corner and in
minutes you can gland yourself some
cocaine God you sound so naive but wait
a second how do you explain the
overwhelming similarities between the
architecture and structure and the
cutting of various stones found in both
of these cultures in fact the evidence
is overwhelming that the exact same
type of Technology in architecture was
used by multiple civilizations across
multiple continents around the world and
it's completely unexplainable oh really
let me tell you something is there like
a stamps trademark in any of these
stones that prove that it's from the
same culture no there isn't
so technically that's not proof of
anything well then how do you explain
the incredible similarities of the
depiction of the third eye or the Eye of
Horus in both cultures or even the very
similar architecture of various
buildings or the use of obelisks or the
elongated skulls or even the swirl marks
found in various pottery or the massive
swirl marks found in the earth that are
hundreds of meters wide I mean you can
even find evidence that they worship the
Sun and had very similar animals facing
the exact same positions and these are
continents apart when you take all these
things into consideration how can you
call all of this just a coincidence you
know what let me ask you a question has
any of this been verified and agreed
upon by peer-reviewed science no it
hasn't
they don't agree with it so it can't be
true in fact I don't want hear any more
about it you know leave me alone leave
me alone I'm right you're wrong I don't
I hate change in fact you know what I've
heard enough I'm going to go put my GMO
red and frozen dinner in the microwave
and eat up because there's obviously
nothing to see here
all right all jokes aside I saved the
best for last
DNA evidence how do you explain the fact
that 30% of all Native American DNA is
middle-eastern that's right in fact this
was verified about a year and a half ago
and scientists have no explanation for
this in fact it completely debunked the
known and currently accepted human
migration patterns that have been
discussed in textbooks for decades but
if you want to hear something even more
crazy they're finding that in various
areas of South America the DNA
originates from get this Aborigines from
Australia and it dates back to 17,000
years ago so how do you explain that and
I should mention that I'm citing a study
done by Harvard and they have absolutely
no explanation for this in fact they're
dumbfounded they have no explanation so
the only logical explanation is that
Plato was right and that many other
civilizations were right when they
carved in stone and stated that there
was once an advanced civilization that
was capable of traveling between the
continents
known as Atlantis I mean when you
consider that Aboriginal DNA is found in
South America as far back as 17,000
years ago and then when you consider
that there is a global Cataclysm that
happened 13,000 years ago it's obvious
that there was a global reset button on
ancient human civilization and that we
were once far more advanced than our
textbooks currently teach in school and
that we were able to travel between the
confidence I mean DNA evidence and
evidence found with cocaine in these
mummies and all the overwhelming
similarities makes it completely
conclusive that these two cultures were
obviously connected in more ways than we
can possibly imagine today real quick I
need to mention that everything that I
share with you today I couldn't have
done without the works of humans are
free calm the works of Richard kisara
who has his own YouTube channel which
you need to check out as well as Richard
cachero calm and check out his book
called the missing link written in stone
I also utilized photos from Graham
Hancock calm as well as an article by
bard Manson with ancient origins dotnet
there's so much evidence that the
history of human civilization is far
older and was once far more advanced
than we're ever taught in school or is
currently being taught in school today
anyways guys I'm Jimmy this is bright
insight like and subscribe I have many
other videos for you enjoy on a whole
wide variety of topics take care
everybody